yep and I saw dark hanataro face - outer
edges happiness ancestors Irma tolerance
and on emotional Booya
when Siddhartha channel amou
haedongcheong Santa de Leon Katara our
hatches your engine
yo prevailing de Landa rocket and sinker
ping hood
[Music]
Dahlia or knife therapy started 2,500
years ago in ancient China as an
alternative method to traditional
medicine romances are Taiwan's Eureka
enforcing the MU 1 ha
NIDA Hangzhou that I was young dal elder
and surf 800 order that out how sooner
hash out certain daniel-san Taunton told
ya ya know yes Angelina Jo has been
practicing in teaching knife therapy for
14 years
whoa cool he's only Benelli alpha he
banned another thought you told heart
itself always haters with hope and how I
saw some Sin City oh [ __ ] non-singular
so that's how you settling it with
chains and Mahato I knew it without
sickle the whole tonight sat down since
Alice is your hometown
what you're not sure but becoming one of
the 18,000 qualified blade masters takes
real work where I'm had to go home with
the whole force should see me know me
yes oh ma Dallas's Sammy and your
sisters solution is outsource onion
sitting at a fancy pen I sure need your
son young the knives are specially
blunted and are made based on a varied
ratio of steel and iron it is a
customary practice to hover the knives
over burning sandalwood and store the
next two meteorites to maintain the
knives lightness and efficiency me :
yeah she could succeed at all truth so
you Amadou ba-dump-bump a young female
foundation being okay sweeping on the
moon while the idea of knives may seem
unconventional this tradition has seen a
recent surge in popularity across
taiwanese cities say taiwan i'm more the
function oma tolerance youngsil Curzon
put on the kava since I should uh she
should see because Eternal Father Knows
Omaha
munimji O'Banion's lighter Thalia Thalia
how the issue truth-telling why
assumptions new effort enjoy when guru
and as assets in which we only sense
under yet seaman sir - are you chose an
aura hands income
[Music]